hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that comes as a suggestion
from anish giri and his followers
and um i was very amazed when i learned
of this game i have not seen it before
and
when such a game you know slips under my
radar there's usually a very good reason
for it and the reason in this case is
well i was having my heart surgery and i
was not aware this game existed at all
and there was so much you know to catch
up to when i got back from the surgery
and
you know after i recovered and
everything that i did not even check
what was played
when i was away so this is one such game
it was played in the bundesliga
and it is uh well uh many of you
probably have seen it but i haven't and
i imagine
some of you also i haven't had the
pleasure of checking out this game
uh so here you can see uh uh anisha
asked his followers on twitter
uh he says that uh it's a quiz for his
twitter followers there is just one
thing missing on again
excellent youtube chess channel uh what
is it uh and then after people you know
started uh you know giving their
suggestions and everything he said that
there was a game missing
by the great uh dutch grand master
irvine lamey
and that uh that i do not have a single
game by him on this channel
which is true but you know i can't have
a game of everyone there are
simply too many players uh and uh we are
going to cover this one uh you you you
will enjoy it
most definitely you know he's a he's a
great chess player as you'll see in this
game and he also tweets in both english
and dutch so he is very dangerous on
both fronts
uh so without further ado let's check it
out and before i show you the game
uh there is also actual footage of this
uh event
uh so you can click on it the first link
in the description below
uh it's by the green khs classic video
team you know they always deliver the
absolute highest quality footage so
there are some nine minutes of uh
at the beginning of this game so if you
want to enjoy that as well the the
uh video quality is you know as
excellent as always so uh that being
said uh let's check out the game
so uh even with the white pieces opens
with d4 we have knight to f6 by fabi uh
c4
e6 knight to f3 and d5 now going for the
queen's gambit declined
we have knight to c3 and here fabi goes
for h6
now i don't know if you remember in 2019
uh there was a game fabi also played in
bundesliga against
peter leko he had this exact same
position but he played
a6 so here i guess fabi likes such
positions in the bundesliga he decides
that a6 is a bit maybe too dangerous i'm
gonna go with h6 so
uh let's see how that works out uh we
have bishop to f4 by irvin
uh bishop to b4 uh and now there are a
couple of games where this position was
reached uh
moves like e3 were played quinte for
check was played a3 was played
uh but the move edwin plays it was never
played before so after c
captures on d5 uh it is already as of
move six that we have a completely new
game
so fabulous is not a problem i'm gonna
capture with the knight now there's a
double attack on the knight here the
knight is also pinned and cannot move
and i'm attacking your bishop so
uh we have bishop back to d2 and here
fabi just castles
so uh everything makes sense and now
if you had this position and you were
thinking about maybe what moves to play
moves like e4 come to mind then we might
have a trade let's say captures captures
the bishop goes back or something like
that
but here erwin actually goes for g3 now
he prepares the fiance to his light
square bishop
and he asks fabi what do you play here
and here father plays knight
captures on c3 which of course is not a
mistake but it's maybe
a bit anti-positional and you know
nothing was forcing this knight to
capture so maybe either wait for your
opponent to to do something or not
but okay fab is a 2800 player uh hard to
question
uh such moves but okay b captures in c3
we have bishop back to a5
and now again well you might be
expecting something like bishop to g2
castles e4 and so on
here evan goes for g4 and already when i
saw this move this is only move 10
i immediately uh knew this was going to
be a great game as
already two of the moves surprised me
and you know i'm pretty sure good things
will happen here
so here uh fabi decides okay you're
attacking me on the king's side i'm
going to counter attack on the center uh
on the
in the center of the board which is a
principle the thing to do when your
opponent attacks
on one side of the board you usually
want to counter attack either on the
other side or in the center of the board
irvin's king is still on e1 so fabi of
course wants to open up the center we
have rook to g1
ideas are now g5 open up the king side
destroy the black king we have knight to
c6 by fabi he says i'm just going to
continue
piling pressure on d4 developing my
pieces and g5 is a bit too soon whenever
white decides to push g file i'm just
going to play h5 and nothing uh
nothing is really happening here so here
after this knight the c6 evan says uh
all right
but what about d captures on c5 and uh
well what are you doing here and the
fabi thought about this and he
he said uh what what am i doing here i
mean
what do i play now i just gave you a
free pawn what can i do
and here fabi decided to push e5 and now
ideas like e4 already come to mind the
the light square bishop now comes alive
so again
uh it's uh it's it's a really weird
position uh never again never before
been reached so
now let's see what happens so a g5
always met with h5 so let's not
play that we with queen to c2 sort of a
preparation for uh
a nice g5 push uh and here fabi goes
rook to e8 and rook the e8 is preparing
e4 but this is one of those positions
where you want to
do before you prepare because e4 here is
very very strong for black because now
you either have to move the knight which
is
not not very good there really isn't a
good square for the knight
uh and other than that if you capture
for example then rook the e8 really
really becomes strong the queen is now
under attack you have to move the queen
where to move it doesn't really matter
wherever you move it
you're gonna get queen f6 now
threatening queen captures an f3 because
of the pin
along the e file and uh well it's uh
it's a very nice position for black uh
so not
not something you you wanna allow so uh
instead of this uh uh rook the e8 by
fabi e for definitely an idea
so rook to e8 like we said and only now
g5
and now g5 makes h6 a bit of a problem
because
h5 a bit of a problem because you go if
you go h5 now that now g6 is very strong
as the queen is on c2
uh you don't really have the option of
capturing because if you capture queen
captures that's it there's no defense
uh whatever you play queen e7 defends
this knight g5
and uh well there is nothing black can
do here
so after this g6 move you would have to
resort to something like f6 but
then again e4 and it's a very very ugly
position to play
uh many great ideas for white here and
not
none whatsoever for black bishop is
coming to c4
uh even queen b3 is a possibility the
bishop can go to h6
white can even sacrifice this bishop for
some pawn pushing action
so a lot of very uh interesting ideas
for white but okay
after g5 we have g6 by fabi ignoring all
of that
uh and now comes uh uh
okay instead of g6 you could also
capture here that is a possibility
h captures on g5 and now you ask what do
you do for example knight captures
uh but it looks it looks very ugly queen
to h7 is the threat so you have to block
this for example e4
and now what do you play uh if you cast
a queen side queen to d5 maybe play
so it's possible all of this is possible
but this such a crazy game in such
such crazy positions surprised that it's
impossible to cover everything
so okay uh after g5 we have g6 by fabi
now sacrificing a pawn and white
captures it we have uh g captures on h6
and now e4 you don't want to allow any
sneaky ideas like rook captures f
captures queen captures followed by
queen to g7
checkmate so e4 we have to block the
queen
and now knight to g5 and now again you
have to be extremely careful
black is uh well black has to be very
very careful what it does here with
bishop to f5 now with
ideas of e3 with an attack on the bishop
and on
irwin's queen here on c2 but aaron
boldly castles we have queen side
castles
and now he says you're welcome to play
e3 but it's not um
well it's not much of a move because if
you play e3 now
i'm going to capture it and open up a
discovery towards your queen and after
bishop captures i'm going to play rook
captures on d8
rook captures on d8 and now king
captures on c2
and remember you you already gave me a
pawn so i'm up material
you have four pawns i have seven so
that's pretty you know pretty big deal
also i'm up a pawn
i'm up a piece uh it's not gonna
uh it's simply not gonna work and not up
a piece but
black has two rooks and two pieces white
has a rook and three pieces
so it's uh you know black didn't really
achieve anything here white would be
completely winning
so instead after this queenside castles
we have queen to f6 by fabi but now
uh now the problem comes we have bishop
to h3
and this is an extremely strong move uh
because what do you play here
again you could play a developing move
like rook 8 to d8 and then you allow for
example bishop captures queen captures
now h4 h5 you must open the position and
that's just it there's not much for
black to do here
another thing you could do you could
capture on h3 and simply allow knight
captures on h3 but now again what do you
play
it seems that black here is without uh
any sort of a meaningful move
uh just to illustrate uh okay you
probably best is to somehow bring this
bishop back into the game because
you don't really have a good way of
activating the rooks uh you can never
move this knight if you ever move this
knight and this knight loses control of
d4 then
this bishop comes to d4 it's uh it's not
going to be
pleasant if you try 95 bishop here goes
after
here and that's just it there's nothing
for you to play uh you you have to go
back and that's
you know just giving giving white a free
move knight
knight g5 and now you're getting crushed
for example you could even give up the
c3 pawn queen captures and now you go
h7 check king to g7 queen captures on c3
bishop captures and now
rook to d7 and that's it you're
attacking here you're attacking here
uh there's nothing uh nothing black can
do so it's a you know
a sea of possibilities after this bishop
to h3 move
so instead fabi goes for e3 it does seem
to be objectively best
and now comes bishop captures on f5 and
now not
queen captures this would be extremely
dangerous if you did this then just
bishop captures on e3
uh and again what do you do here queen
captures with
czech king captures uh white is
completely winning rook a to d8
now comes rook to d6 and black all of
black's pieces are completely tied down
and even without the queens
of the board you can never allow bishop
d4 because then h7 is just crushing
so instead after this bishop captures an
f5 uh we have
e captures on d2 with check
and now rook captures on d2 and now rook
to e5 by fabi
uh interestingly you can't go for this g
captures on f5 then just knights the e4
check wins the queen
so that's out of the question and even
capturing with the queen is out of the
question
uh because then queen captures g
captures and h7 check
uh again it's a game over if you go king
to f8
uh well king to f8 is even a good king
to h8
on the other hand just knight captures
on f7 with check and that's it king
captures on h7 you're gonna get rooked
to d6 and you're getting uh
checkmated here there's nothing you can
do about it uh and
instead of king to f8 not much better if
king to f8 again
just rook to d7 and all the same ideas
apply
uh not not much to do here uh you don't
uh rook captures on f7 will be checkmate
so if you go kg7
just h8 queen you can even do this and
now we get the exact same position that
we had if the king went to h8
just knife captures an f7 check king h7
rook to d6
and that's it you're getting checkmated
if you're you know that kind of a player
you can throw in a nice rook to e6 but
still after captures you're still
getting checkmated
so after rook captures on d2 fabi went
with rook to
e5 but it simply isn't enough uh here
irving goes for
knight captures on f7 and this is a
beautiful beautiful way to continue this
attack
and just you know in in the spirit of
the paul morphy saga that
we are currently covering and there is
no good move here uh objectively best of
course is to ignore the knight and play
rook captures on f5 but this loses by
force
knight to d6 and now what do you play
the rook is under attack if you move the
rook then the g6 pawn
becomes vulnerable you will you you're
going to lose the queen
so here it's pretty much forced you have
to go bishop captures on c3
queen captures on f5 now bishop captures
and b2 with
check at least you want to grab a little
bit of material before deciding what uh
what's happening so king captures and
now queen captures on f5
knight captures and that's it for
example king h7 knight back to d6 and
uh this is completely unplayable uh
white has
six pawns black has three uh the end
game is completely winning for
erwin so after knight captures on f7
fabi says all right the objectively best
move is losing for me so i'm gonna have
to go with the flow queen
captures on f7 and you know hope for the
best
but now bishop captures on g6 attacking
the queen
and here fabi plays queen captures uh on
f2
but the problem is uh although it seems
like black defended and
there are a lot of very interesting
moves that black can play uh white
is completely winning if white if white
finds one move that
is not easy to find so feel free to
pause the video here and
win the game for irvin while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
not playing anything weird and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's
bishop to f7 check i know some of you
were thinking about bishop to h7 check
but then after king to h8 you you have
no way of continuing the attack and then
it's
just all black so instead uh
congratulations once again to everyone
who found bishop the f7 with czech such
a wonderful idea the bishop can be
captured
the bishop can be ignored you can do a
lot of things here uh but
not on none of the ideas work uh so here
we're just gonna show what happens if
you play
something like let's say king captures
on f7 so
this uh loses by force you allow queen
to h7 and that's just it king f6 you're
gonna get rook to d6 with
check rook to e6 and now even queen to
g6
with check of course king e5 queen
captures on e6 and now that's it king f4
and rook to g4 will be checkmate the
black king has no more squares
so uh uh capturing the bishop is
definitely not an option after bishop to
f7 so what else you could do you could
play
king to f8 uh but uh let's see let's see
what happens if you try that
rook to g8 check king to e7 and
now rook captures an a8 you just lose
the material
and there's no way to recover if you go
for the bishop queen captures
queen d3 and again what do you play here
if you try queen e6 trying to prevent
queen from reaching d7
queen h7 check so and anything works
here queen f7 now even rook to d7 check
you can give up a rook for
for a queen here rookie seven and now
queen to d5 check for example king to c7
and that's it
uh queen to d6 checkmate so uh not
working after bishop to f7 is obviously
this this doesn't work so how about king
to h
it can we do that we could also capture
with the queen that's also a possibility
uh no of course we can because it's a
double check so after king to h8
uh now comes the queen to g6 now
threatening queen to g7
checkmate and here there is no good way
to defend uh if you could somehow grab
hold of the dark
of this diagonal maybe it's possible but
the rook is in the way so here bishop
captures and c3 does nothing
but fab is resourceful and favi finds
brook to g5 it
it prolongs game for one more move but
allows bishop captures on c3 to defend
the g7 square so very resourceful uh
we have rook captures and g5 again
threatening checkmate
and now uh of course bishop captures on
c3 guarding the g7 square
uh and here we have king to c2 attacking
this bishop and this is just a wonderful
move you don't care about the rook
because the bishop can never move this
diagonal if you move the bishop away of
course queen to g7 will be checkmate
so here we have knight to e7 and
now comes a a wonderful wonderful move a
queen to e4
so what do you do here the knight is
under attack you don't really have a
a good way of doing any damage to the
white king so here
fabi goes back bishop to f6 attacks and
defends
and now comes rook to e5
now with a double attack on the knight
and of course black can never afford
to give up the well this because then
just uh well
you're completely doomed here uh king h7
queen to g7 checkmate
or you have to part with the queen after
queen to f6
with the same result so after rook to e5
we have rook to
f8 now saying okay you capture here i'm
gonna capture here it's not a problem
uh but here comes a bishop backed okay
first uh you could move the bishop but
first e3
uh opening up this second rank for the
for the white rook with queen to f1
and now comes the bishop to c4 bishop to
c for now is stronger as it comes with
tempo the queen is uh well
under attack here so queen to a1
and now uh you know a very tricky square
for the queen because
well there's not much to do there but
you are attacking the rook on e5 twice
uh and here the position is completely
winning for er erwin and you can play a
lot of moves here that are winning he
played one
such move uh but there is a move that is
uh you know
uh in style and in beauty greater than
all others and we are in the midst of
the morphe saga
so just for that feel free to pause the
video and try to find
this well in my opinion the the most
beautiful way of
ending the game while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it once again congratulations
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show uh it's rook the d4
and this is uh this is a real beauty
because now
uh the the queen has no access to the e5
rook and you don't really care about
bishop captures rook
because this is just completely winning
now once you eliminate the dark square
bishop you're just getting checkmated
there's
no no defense against this so what you
would have to do
after rook to d4 is just resign or try
to play some weird moves like
knight to g8 maybe but it should not
work
rook to e8 goes after the rook and now
okay you can capture on d4 finally but
now rook captures an f8 and if queen to
c3 check
king to d1 and what do you play here uh
there is no move if queen captures here
you're just going to play queen captures
on d4 and that's
it captures captures and now there this
is just pointless
to continue for black but like i said
all of the moves are winning here this
is just the one i
uh i thought was uh the the most
enjoyable
uh edmond played rook captures on e7
which is of course uh justice winning
and there's nothing much for fabi to do
here fabi continued with queen to c3
check
king to d1 and now comes queen back to
a1 check hoping for a perpetual here
king king c2 queen to c3 checking 31
queen e1 check
but now erin of course did not go for it
he played king to e2
and now finally bishop captures on e7
but it doesn't help
because here uh queen to d4 with
check and this is a sneaky way of ending
the game problem is you don't want to
play queen captures on e7 because you
would
you know you would be sorry queen to f1
is checkmate
if you remember if you remember that
checkmate we said that if you
check the king on a light square and the
dark squares are taken
by your your own pieces then of course
it will be
uh it will be checkmate for those of you
who are maybe new to chess
so that would be a terrible way to end
such a quality game uh so queen to d4
check now just uh you know going into a
nice end game
and it's just as nice as the one that i
said was nicer but
in that game you were you know up in
pawns and also up uh
of the exchange but this works just as
well queen capture spawn captures was
played and now rook to f4
going uh well for for some activity here
bishop to d5 now just going after this
pawn and there's no way to defend it
once you eliminate this pawn then the
past c
pawn will just uh you know be too strong
bishop f6
for some counter play here going after
the d4 pawn uh irving just
defends it we have rooked h for now but
rook to d3 uh we have rooked the h3
check
came to d2 uh fabi grabs the h2 pawn
with czech king to c3
uh this spawn is defended so you don't
really care about that uh but
that's just it king h7 we have bishop
capture some b7 now the c pawn is a
monster
rook captures on a2 as this is now
possible and king b3
uh we have rook to a1 hoping to kind of
stop that
pass pawn uh but you know it's only
wishful thinking so here bishop d8
taking care of the dark square
d5 now so here we have bishop to a5
uh but again not not much to be done
here d6 we have rook to c1
but now comes rook to d5 and after
bishop to d8 you have to play something
you can't go anywhere along this
diagonal because then the pawn just
continues marching forward so bishop to
e8 and here rook to d4 was played
and he was in this position animal 49
that uh fabiano corona resigned the game
and uh this spectacular victory was
achieved by
uh duchy rand master airvin lamy and um
yeah here you resign because there's
nothing you can do rook the c4 will just
cover up
the the c file and that's it whatever
you play here you can just repeat bishop
a5 rook c4
and that's it if rook to d1 just c7
you're gonna promote the pawn to a queen
and that's it
so really a spectacular game with so
many possibilities that it would be i
mean even this video is already taking
too long
and i've only scratched the surface of
of you know how many of them they are
uh so it was a really enjoyable one and
you know i i thought i missed a lot
uh during my surgery and my recovery but
you know seeing this
this game i have really missed a lot who
knows what else i've missed
uh but yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it thank you for
thank you to anish giri and his uh fans
for suggesting this
and you know uh voting properly uh i
would like to thank emmanuel widmer
uh chess heroes kickstarter adrian
singerman uh jeffrey dickerson and
charleston for a contribution to my
channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day